To this day, the origin of Valentine's Day still is not 100% clear.
Regardless,...
...many countries celebrate their own variation of the heart-shaped holiday.
Hey, it's Jordyn Rolling with Buzz60.
My people, the Danish, celebrate Valentine's Day...
...by giving friends and lovers pressed white flowers called snowdrops.
The French are said to be the originators of Valentine's Day cards.
Charles, Duke of Orleans, sent love letters to his wife...
...while imprisoned in 1415.
Sacre bleu!
That sounds like a prison pen pal to me.
South Koreans celebrate on three separate days,...
...with women giving gifts on February 14th, men on March 14th,...
...and the lonely, while eating in comfort, on April 15th.
It's extremely popular to get married on Valentine's Day in the Philippines.
In recent years,...
...hundreds of couples have participated in mass public weddings.
In South Africa, women pin the names of their crushes on their sleeves,...
...allowing men to finally learn of their secret admirers.
Call me, Leo.
Buzz60,...
...now you know, pass it on.